[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIHAI IONESCU: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to another "Payments
Live" Show.
Today we have a very exciting
topic, which is how to
implement, distribute, and
monetize online games.
And, even more exciting,
we have a partner
to talk about it.
From Seattle, please
welcome Matt
Endsley from Carbon Games.
Hi, Matt.
Can you hear us?
MATT ENDSLEY: Hello, yes, yes.
Can you hear me?
MIHAI IONESCU: Sure.
Yes.
So to give a little bit of
context, one of the great
things about Payments APIs is
that we get to work with all
kinds of online technologies
and partners looking to
monetize successful
online apps.
And games is one of
our favorites.
PENG YING: Definitely one
of the favorites.
MIHAI IONESCU: Who wouldn't
like to play games and get
paid for it.
So you can't blame us.
Today we're taking a top-level
view and get an expert opinion
on what it takes to successfully
build a game and
monetize it online.
So Matt, tell us a little bit
more about the Carbon Games,
AirMech, and yourself.
MATT ENDSLEY: So we're
a small studio.
We're about seven people now
in the Seattle area up in
Washington.
We've been making games together
for a while now, the
core group of us.
And we just wanted to get back
into making small, more
personal games.
We've worked in big, huge
companies before.
We wanted to get back to that
making core games that we
enjoy playing.
That's kind of the background
story for how we started
working on AirMech.
PENG YING: Cool.
And then your current
games, so AirMech.
Let's jump into AirMech.
What is it?
I actually have it on my
computer right now so we can
show off a little bit
of what you can do.
MIHAI IONESCU: Oh, so now we're
playing games live?
PENG YING: Yeah.
Food lovers live, playing
games live.
MIHAI IONESCU: Perfect
use of our time.
PENG YING: So why don't you talk
through a little bit of
what's going on on-screen.
We are in the midst of--
I guess it looks
like a battle.
MATT ENDSLEY: Yes.
The AI has kind of overrun
us right now while
we're waiting to play.
PENG YING: We're
in a bad place.
MATT ENDSLEY: At the core of
it, AirMech, we call it an
action strategy game.
So you immediately notice
that you're
controlling a main hero.
You're flying around as this
transforming robot, and
there's enemy transforming
robots that are trying to
destroy your base.
And then on top of that, there's
this lightweight RTS
element where you are building
units and commanding units on
the field to assist
your main hero.
PENG YING: Got it.
MATT ENDSLEY: So if you're
familiar with a League of
Legends or a DOTA style game,
it'll have kind of the same
feel to it, but you're the one
actually controlling the
creeps and controlling what's
spawned and where.
So it's definitely a bit
more of a strategy
game than your typical--
PENG YING: And then
are there any--
MATT ENDSLEY: --action game.
PENG YING: --strategies that we
can use right now to push
back the AI?
MATT ENDSLEY: The biggest ones
you'll see, these little
runner guys that are spawning on
the map, they are trying to
capture these outposts.
And so you'll see these outposts
have these little
lights on top of them.
And when four guys go in, the
outpost becomes yours.
You can heal over it, you can
regenerate energy over it, and
you can also pick up units
that you build.
So if you use the mouse wheel
or if you use the Q button,
you can pull down
your build menu.
That shows what units you
can build on the map.
PENG YING: Oh, man.
MATT ENDSLEY: And when the unit
is ready, you can fly
over any of the buildings
that you control.
PENG YING: We're getting hurt.
MATT ENDSLEY: In our case,
any blue building, yeah.
And you can pick up those
units from any
building you control.
So these little guys running,
they're weak, but they're
really important because they
are what establishes your
bases in the map.
PENG YING:OK.
And then what's the end
goal of this game?
What am I trying
to accomplish?
MATT ENDSLEY: If you fly
carefully to the right side of
the map, there's this giant red
base that the AI's built
up right now.
And our goal is to destroy
that base.
PENG YING: Yeah, I
think I found it.
MIHAI IONESCU: You're
doing pretty well.
PENG YING: I play a little bit
of games in my free time.
MATT ENDSLEY: And so the enemy's
trying to do the same
thing, and you'll find that your
healer unit isn't very
effective at damaging
the base.
And so it's important to build
up an army and strategically
move it across the map
to destroy the base.
PENG YING: Got it.
I think one of the awesome
things about this is that,
hey, look, we're playing
within the browser.
MATT ENDSLEY: Yes.
PENG YING: So for everybody
that thought that this was
your standard PC game, this is
actually accessible on all
devices that support Chrome.
MIHAI IONESCU: How
is that possible?
How do you do that?
PENG YING: What are you using
to enable this high-quality,
high-fidelity graphics
within the browser?
MATT ENDSLEY: Google has this
new technology called Native
Client that--
I guess it shipped sometime last
fall, is when it first
started coming out in public
releases of Chrome.
And it basically allows you to
run a C++ application inside
of Chrome's sandbox.
And so you get you get the power
of running native code
but still have the security
model that you'd normally
expect from something like doing
HTML5 and JavaScript.
So we can take what normally is
a PC or a console game and
hook right into the GPU and run
the exact same code that
we'd be running in our native
PCR or native console versions
of the game inside
the browser.
PENG YING: Sweet.
So I'm guessing that
this is like pretty
cutting edge stuff.
I haven't worked with it.
I've heard that it launched,
and I've helped a few
developers implement Payment
APIs for it.
But since you've already dived
into it, are there any lessons
learned that you can share with
other developers about
your experiences in integrating
NaCl, or Native Client?
MATT ENDSLEY: Yes.
I'd say a lot of them carry
over to any sort of game
development thing where you're
talking about working on
multiple platforms.
It's just making sure that your
code is easily portable.
We went into AirMech knowing
we're going to be working on
multiple platforms and so we had
the advantage of building
everything from the ground up
to make it as cross platform
as possible.
But it's definitely something
you want to keep in mind
because NaCl's more like
developing on Linux than it
would be developing on
a traditional Windows
development environment
that most developers
are familiar with.
MIHAI IONESCU: Looks
awesome to me.
I didn't realize you started
in the browser.
I knew it worked in the browser,
but I thought you
were just sharing your screen.
PENG YING: If there are more
games like this, it'll be
trouble for productivity.
MIHAI IONESCU: So Matt, let's
talk a little bit about
another important aspect that
game developers are facing.
You build a great game, but
now you have to put it in
front of a lot of people.
In this case, going the browser
way enabled you to
distribute it much more
easily to places like
the Chrome Web Store.
Tell us a little bit how has
that impacted adoption, the
fact that your game now
runs in the browser.
MATT ENDSLEY: Chrome Web Store
is definitely great from just
that people know they can go
and find stuff that runs in
the browser.
One of the biggest hurdles we
had is that when you tell
normal game media sites, normal
gamers, that your game
runs in a browser, they have
this tendency to dismiss it
because they don't realize
what you can actually do.
The Chrome Web Store is a good
place to show off that kind of
game because it's a centralized
place where you
can find high-quality
applications.
MIHAI IONESCU: Cool.
And it makes it easier to use
all kind of frameworks and
technologies that have already
been built for the browser.
All open source.
MATT ENDSLEY: We didn't have
to worry about patching or
versioning.
PENG YING: Now that we've seen
the game a little bit, can we
talk a little bit about
the metagame?
That's the game built
on top of the game.
I'm going to jump out of this
game right now and show the
viewers a little bit of
what the metagame is.
It's basically a way to engage
players outside of the core
gameplay itself and then
incentivize them to come back
and keep playing,
stuff like that.
But Matt can probably do a way
better time defining what's
going on or what
I'm looking at.
So tell me what you want to show
off about the metagame.
MATT ENDSLEY: Yeah, so if you
go at the top level of your
UI, you should have a big
Customize button.
And at the core of it, every
game that you play, win or
lose, you're gaining experience
that slowly
increases the level of your
out-of-game character.
So you gain experience and
levels in game, but every time
you go into game, that resets.
So every game is a fresh
beginning as
far as gameplay goes.
But then out of the game, you
have your own level that
allows you to unlock
new units.
We took an approach with AirMech
that we didn't want it
to be that units were
necessarily
better than other units.
They're just different.
So you can vary your strategy
by, say, you're taking in some
artillery units instead of
tanks to have a more
long-range strategy for
attacking enemies and try to
outrange them and play
more defensively.
PENG YING: I've noticed that
some of these units are
unlocked, so--
well, continue what you
were talking about.
MATT ENDSLEY: Yes.
Some of them will start on trial
where you could play
with them for free, and then we
kind of rotate those in and
out what's available for
everyone at the beginning.
So every time you play a game
you get experience, and you
also get Kudos, which is one
of our in-game currencies.
We really wanted to make the
game fair from a gamer's
perspective where the more money
you put in, you don't
get a gameplay advantage.
And so everything that affects
gameplay you can unlock with
Kudos, which is what you're
earning while playing.
And then if you click on your
AirMech and you look at the
different AirMechs that you can
play as, you'll see that
each class of AirMechs
has a handful of
different looks to it.
We call them skins, and all they
are is they're cosmetic
differences.
Like the Chrome Sauce
is a good example.
From a gameplay standpoint, it
is identical to the normal
saucer, it just looks
different.
And so it's a way that you can
customize what you look like
in the game.
PENG YING: Cool.
A lot of these look
really sick.
You guys have great artwork.
MATT ENDSLEY: Yeah,
I agree with that.
I can't take any
credit for it.
I work all on the technical
side of things, but I
love the art here.
PENG YING: What about the social
aspects of the game?
Can you talk about the social
aspects at all?
MATT ENDSLEY: Yeah, so we
recently added in what we call
global chat.
And if you have the game open,
it's that window where people
are talking about whatever
random stuff they're talking
about at 10:00 AM
in the morning.
PENG YING: it's a
productive day.
MATT ENDSLEY: Just having a
window where people can talk
about nonsense with everyone
tends to let people--
they stay in the game longer.
They're more engaged.
We find that there's players
that enjoy just hanging out to
chat, and they don't actually
play the game, which
was weird for us.
And one of the things we do is
everyone on every platform and
version can talk with
everyone else.
So even if you're a version
behind and haven't patched
yet, you can still get into
this global chat room.
We find that in addition to
having that staying power of
keeping people in the game, that
it also works as kind of
like a crowd-sourced support
group where people come in,
they'll have a question about
something, and other players
will be able to answer
it for us.
MIHAI IONESCU: That's awesome.
So we saw multiple technologies
coming together--
the game, the browser, with
the new Native Client
technologies, using the metagame
and all kinds of
skinning and nice graphics and
special effects, and, of
course, the social aspect, which
makes the game so much
more interesting.
But there is one more step to
really make it profitable and
a nice successful business for
a developer, and that's
monetizing the game.
You mentioned, briefly, you're
using a freemium model--
MATT ENDSLEY: Right.
MIHAI IONESCU: --for the game.
Everyone can play for free.
Tell us a little bit about
your strategy.
How do you monetize the game?
MATT ENDSLEY: So it's a
free-to-play game, where the
core game, you can get it, and
you can play it for free.
And then we charge for cosmetic
upgrades like the
AirMech skins.
And we also charge for time
unlock, so if you don't want
to play like 10 games to unlock
some cool unit, you can
pay a dollar or something
to unlock it.
It's time shortcuts and
cosmetic things.
We kind of viewed it as, if
you remember the mid '90s,
shareware was a huge
thing back then.
And it's kind of getting back
to that same type of model,
where you have a demo version of
the game that you can play,
and then if you really enjoy
the game, you end up paying
money for it.
MIHAI IONESCU: What APIs are
you using to monetize?
MATT ENDSLEY: We use three right
now in our main game.
We use Google Wallet, we use
Amazon Payments, and we also
use PayPal.
MIHAI IONESCU: Awesome.
And it made it easier to
integrate in the browser how
was the entire API process?
MATT ENDSLEY: Actually,
it was.
It was pretty easy.
So we built our own servers that
handle the server-side
back end for the billing
process.
And having it in the browser,
especially with Google Wallet,
makes for a really smooth
transition for purchasing
things without having to open a
new tab or switch to another
application.
MIHAI IONESCU: Cool.
Great.
Any lessons learned and tips
and tricks suggestions for
developers looking to monetize
their games similarly to what
you've been doing?
MATT ENDSLEY: I would say get
your game up and running as
fast as possible and get to
the point where you can
actually charge people for it.
I think a lot of people
underestimate the point at
which people will start paying
money for something.
I think, from a monetization
standpoint, just getting to
the point where you have the
ability to charge people for
stuff forces you to get your
game done and forces your
prioritize.
Once you start having revenue,
you're forced to work on
what's really important instead
of having these long
far off deadlines that
are kind of nebulous.
MIHAI IONESCU: That's nice.
PENG YING: Speaking of getting
your game done, you told us
earlier that the engine that
you guys built for 3D
rendering is open sourced.
MATT ENDSLEY: Yes.
We have a culture here of
contributing back to community.
We use a lot of open source
technology to build the game,
and so we thought it wouldn't
be fair to use all the stuff
that's built up by the great
software community without
contributing back.
And so on GitHub, we have our
rendering engine, our network
API, and a handful of other
platform level stuff things
for audio and core-level
libraries.
PENG YING: That's
really awesome.
If somebody wanted to build off
your open source platform,
where should they search?
What should they search
for on GitHub?
MATT ENDSLEY: The easiest way
to do it is if you go to
carbongames.com/
opensource.html.
It will have a link to all the
open source stuff that we use,
including our own.
It's our central repository
for what we're using
to build the game.
PENG YING: If somebody just
wants to play the game, where
do they go?
MATT ENDSLEY: That's
really easy.
You can just go to airmech.com,
and it will have
instructions on how to
get it right there.
PENG YING: Awesome.
MIHAI IONESCU: All right.
Thank you, Matt.
Very insightful and expert
opinion on how you guys
implemented the game.
We have a few questions on the
Moderator related to this.
People found out that you were
coming on, and we made sure we
had some questions
ready for you.
So here is one.
"Do you have any recommendations
for pricing
virtual goods?
What is the optimal transaction
amount?" You can
talk about AirMech or if you
guys have other thoughts to
share from other games.
MATT ENDSLEY: I'm not really
sure what it is.
I'm certain if you found someone
with a degree in
economics, they could probably
tell you how all this works.
But we kind of played around
with a bunch of them, and we
settled on price points around
$0.59, $1.99, $5.99 is what
our big ones used to be.
And then we started doing this
thing where we bundled a bunch
of in-game currency
at a huge value.
It's like four to five times
value of what it would be if
you bought it normally, and
then we charged $10, like
$9.99 for that.
And that's our predominant
sale right now, is these
bundles that--
I don't know how to
best describe it.
You anchor a price point, and
then you have a good value,
and people will go for that.
MIHAI IONESCU: I think
you put it best.
Someone can write a PhD
dissertation on what's the
optimal pricing strategy.
And from what we also saw, we
have a bunch of games on
Google and also on
Chrome Web Store.
Developers are experimenting
with various price levels and
various bundles.
It depends on your game flow.
You have to gather a lot of
analytics and a lot of data.
MATT ENDSLEY: As you say, one
thing that's important is make
sure that you can track the
success of whatever you're
changing and then don't be
afraid to change stuff.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yes,
absolutely.
Experiment with it, and I
think our recommendation
endorses, play around with
various price points, test it,
reiterate, and see where
most of your
revenue is coming from.
PENG YING: Do any of your
customers feel burned if they
purchase something and then
later on see it for a
different price?
Or is it that every time you
introduce a new item, you're
playing with the price a
little bit that way?
MATT ENDSLEY: Sometimes we do
do things like we put our
bundles on sale for
like 30% off.
And so far, we really haven't
seen a negative backlash from
someone who bought something
at full price and
then it goes on sale.
I think customers in the gaming
space are kind of used
to that, that there's these
cycles of things that go on
sale and come off of sale.
So it's not something that's
been a big issue for us.
MIHAI IONESCU: We'll keep an
eye on your next sale.
PENG YING: Black Friday.
Cyber Monday, Cyber Monday.
I guess it'll be a
post-Christmas sale this time.
MIHAI IONESCU: Make
sure I get lots of
ammo for my next conquest.
OK, one more question.
Let's see, what do
we have here.
So we have a question about the
Payments Merchant accounts.
The question is, "Do you use a
single merchant account for
multiple games or one Merchant
account for every game?
Which option do you
think is better?"
MATT ENDSLEY: So right now, we
only have the one game, and we
have one merchant account.
I can't see going forward trying
to split games between
merchant accounts.
I would imagine that we'd just
keep one merchant account.
We do a bunch of our own
reporting outside of what the
Google Wallet API does on the
Wallet merchant page, and
that's mainly so that we can
collate data from all of our
payment providers.
So if we're going to be doing
filtering by gaming, it would
be at a higher level than at
the payment provider level.
I don't know if I'd see an
advantage to doing multiple
merchant accounts.
MIHAI IONESCU: Makes sense.
And probably we can also do
a better job at providing
developers with more features on
the Merchant Center site so
they get some benefit of
using one merchant
account versus others.
And on our side, we have seen
people go both ways.
If you have a few games but not
that many transactions,
then you can definitely just
stay with one merchant account
and keep using it for
multiple games.
If you see a lot of transactions
coming in, then
it's probably better to have one
merchant account per game.
So it's a personal preference,
and as always, we are looking
for feedback from developers and
suggestions on what extra
features we need to add to the
Merchant Center to make that
hassle-free and a better
experience for the developer.
PENG YING: We should suit
everybody's needs to satisfy
as much of the developer
needs as possible.
Anything else?
MIHAI IONESCU: Any final
thoughts, Matt?
MATT ENDSLEY: I just say if
you're interested in games,
just go and start making them.
See where it takes you.
MIHAI IONESCU: Fantastic.
And everyone, if you want to
join us playing AirMech, you
can find it at carbongames.com.
You can search for it on
the Chrome Web Store.
PENG YING: Airmech.com.
It's all over the place.
MIHAI IONESCU: It's all over.
Great.
Thank you a lot, Matt.
Before we finish, I have a few
announcements to make.
One is related to our online
documentation.
We are looking for developer
feedback on how to improve it,
and we just added
a feedback link.
You'll see at the top
right of every page.
So anything you find wrong with
the documentation or you
want to improve it, have
suggestions, please click on
that link and let us know.
And the second announcement.
We just have a new device
launched a couple of days ago,
which comes pre-loaded with
Google Wallet, is the Samsung
Galaxy Axiom.
So one more fun phone
to play with and
play with Google Wallet.
So with that said, thank
you Matt, once again.
MATT ENDSLEY: Thank you guys.
MIHAI IONESCU: And let's go--
PENG YING: See you
in two weeks.
MIHAI IONESCU: Go play
some AirMech and see
everyone in two weeks.
Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]